So what humans do,
that specialist,
we absorb all of these ideas,
all these inputs and we switched them up
in various ways and come up with new
things.
And so there are essentially three main
ways that the brain does this and we've
summarize this as bending and breaking
and blending.
So let's start with bending.
Bending is where you take something and
you,
you change it,
you make it smaller,
you make it bigger,
you change something about it.
When you look at statues across human
culture,
you find that that um,
people bend the human form any which
way,
making it taller,
skinnier,
emphasizing certain portions over the
other.
They do that with all animal paintings
and sculptures and so on.
You can bend lots of aspects of things.
So the artist Jr made a statue of the
high jumper,
Mohammed Idris,
uh,
for the Olympics and he put that super
huge and had him jumping over a
building.
And you have other sculptors that make
extremely tiny little figurines.
And one of the arguments we make is that
the exact same thing that's happening in
art,
the same cognitive processes are
happening in the sciences.
Also,
so you see exactly this kind of thing
happening all the time.
Just as an example,
in the early days of driving in the
1920s,
headlight glare was a real problem.
So Edwin land,
um,
the scientist realized that he could
solve this by using polarizing crystals,
but those were very big at the time.
So he figured out how to shrink these
down and make a windshield out of all
these little polarized crystals.
It's exactly the same sort of Aha moment
as the artist who's making these tiny
figurines.
It's the same kind of bend going on.
And we see this all over in,
in biology.
Just as one example,
the artificial heart,
um,
since it was invented in the 1980s has
been a mechanical pump,
but these are very energy hungry and
they get worn down.
And so in 2004,
a couple of physicians came up with a
continuous flow heart where blood flows
through and is oxygenated continuously.
So if you have one of these hearts,
you don't have a pulse at all.
Dick Cheney has one of these and he
doesn't have a pulse.
And so,
um,
this is a bend of what we find in
nature.
We get the idea of the heart and then we
bend it to make it compatible with what
we want.
And of course the airplanes are,
are a bend of,
you know,
what we witnessed birds doing and so on.
So there are many ways that you can bend
things and this is one of the great
things that the brain does all the time.
So breaking is where you take some
things,
some input that you've received and you
busted into pieces,
maybe leave pieces out or something like
that.
So just as an example,
um,
the artist cory archangel took the video
game,
Super Mario Brothers and he hacked into
it and he removed everything except for
the little clouds.
And then he made an art installation
where it was just the clouds and he
called it Super Mario Clouds.
What he was doing was taking part of it
away,
leaving part of it there.
That same kind of overt creativity that
happens in the arts is exactly what
happens in the scientific lab all the
time where you take certain parts away.
For example,
in my field,
there's a method that's used now in
neuroscience called clarity,
where you take the,
the brain,
which you can't see inside of,
and you wash away all the fatty
molecules so that you can see where the
pathways originate and where they go.
And in that way you can essentially make
part of the brain transparent.
You can suddenly see the pathways.
It's the exact same idea.
Just as another example,
um,
the artist David Hockney,
uh,
takes the,
the visual field and breaks it up into
pieces.
And the impressionist painters,
Surat,
um,
does pointillism.
So there's,
there's these sort of big dots and
you're seeing these dots.
If you come up close,
you see them.
If you go far away,
it looks like a,
a painting.
And this exact same sort of breaking is
the innovation that underlies our whole
digital universe because there's
pixelation of everything you see on a
computer screen.
It's a bunch of individual squares that
have different colors.
And at the right distance,
you see me talking on a big think video.
Fred sanger was trying to figure out how
to sequence long molecules of DNA.
And he realized that he could break
these up into smaller pieces and then
you can analyze and correlate the
information.
He actually ended up winning two Nobel
prizes for this work that he did,
and it's the basis of essentially
everything we know about genomes at this
point,
but it's all the same cognitive
operations that are happening that you
see both in the art and in the sciences.
What happens in the arts is overt
bending,
breaking and blending.
So you see all kinds of art projects
where people are taking things in,
they're bending them and in size or
texture or they're breaking them,
they're breaking pieces off or they're
blending two ideas.
This is the basis of all of the art that
we see exactly the same mechanisms are
happening in the scientific lab.
It's just that typically we can't see
them.
So when you pick up your cell phone,
it's this little rectangle that is
absolutely chock full of creativity,
of really brilliant ideas that went into
the making of that.
But you can't see it because it's just a
little,
you know,
enclosed thing.
But the interesting part is it's,
it's exactly the same cognitive
mechanisms,
which is to say absorbing the world,
bending,
breaking and blending it and spinning
out new versions of things.
One of the things that we love about our
computers is that we can put information
in there and then when we pull it out a
year later,
it's exactly the same.
It's exactly the same zeros and ones.
The human brain doesn't work that way.
When you put stuff in,
it gets switched up with other things
that have come in before.
And what comes out are,
you know,
new versions of things.
So blending is where you have two
completely separate ideas and then these
become blended in the brain and
something new comes out.
So just as an example,
uh,
in ancient mythology,
we see this all throughout where you
have a,
for example,
a man and the why and,
and,
and you got a sphinx or you get all over
the world,
different combinations,
Elian and a goat.
You get a chimera.
Um,
exactly the same thing happens in the
lab.
Just as one example,
um,
scientists have long wanted to harvest
spider silk,
which is actually stronger than steel
for its size,
but you can't get a bunch of spiders
together or they'll eat each other.
So what a geneticists did as he spliced
out the gene that makes spider silk and
put it in a goat and made freckles the
spider goat who secretes spider silk in
her milk.
She's a real life Kymera.
And this idea of taking two separate
things in blending them is something
that,
uh,
humans do all the time.
We take very different concepts and we
put them together.
Okay.